I enroll in Stanford innovation in
entrepreneurship certificate program
because he's one of the best program to
prepare entrepreneurship specialists not
only by heart but also having some
academic approach having developed
interest in children's book writing I
was looking for a program that would
offer a mix of all the different things
that I should be equipped with to start
to embark upon my new journey the
variety of courses which were offered to
me and different fields it was in
leadership it was in strategy it was in
product development and marketing which
is a lot if any certificate could give
you like those kind of options and you
could choose like what you want to learn
I think that is super empowering you
learning stuff you're using this now
much right away you're getting feedback
from professors and this is where how
you can be successful in your business
and with this product all the course
material and the assignments were also
so real so appealing that I would never
hesitate to work past midnight after
putting my kids all to bed and and still
with passion would work on these
assignments it's so based on practical
examples each of the course which you go
through they are actually talking to you
about the startups and you know what
were their challenges the fact that it
was practical based and we actually got
exposure to a lot of case studies as
well you know which happens in business
school so having that kind of exposure
and access to material is so creative
stuff has this vision in understanding
how to teach people this is very
exciting I think that has me
mean to very confident professional it
has been super impactful in my life
[Music]
you